and sit
down just look straight ahead that's
really good there that be
great I like that
I am an autistic person it is obvious
when you see me I have no voice but
yearn to say so much if you are willing
to listen I will try to say how I
feel I live in a total blur of
information if I have too many people in
a room at one time and one place it is
too overwhelming for me to have to
process I have to jiggle my brain to
make it
settle it's just how I
cope water takes my pain away because it
allows me to lose myself in a place that
asks no questions of my
abilities every drop lets me be
me before I could communicate through
typing I remember that I was frustrated
by people who were kind but didn't know
my brain was as good as people who can
speak I remember being being told that I
liked the Teletubbies which I did but I
wanted to move on and was desperate to
read books for my
age now I have the chance to speak up
for people like
me I'm speaking from my
heart non-verbal people are pleasing to
be around because we sense the world in
a deeper way than those who
talk because we cannot express our
emotions instantly we become deep
thinkers people
Watchers we have the same dreams as
everyone else so please don't treat us
[Music]
differently each of us is a
star eager to be discovered and named in
the
atmosphere if you acknowledge our
abilities we can shine
brighter we have so much to
say please hear us
[Music]
[Applause]
I think we're all better people for
knowing muray he's made such a big
difference to all our lives we can
actually understand how deeply he thinks
about things he's very privileged to be
part of his life his whole experience is
expressed there in just a few minutes
it's it's wonderful wonderful that just
some up everything about Mar and it's
just lovely to be telling us how his
world is I am
happy
that
the
world
can
see the
real
[Music]
me thanks for watching if you enjoyed
that be sure to to check out these
videos next and if you haven't already
hit the Subscribe button and click the
Bell to get a notification each time we
upload a new video